summer is the best time of the year to
get your carpets clean so ben mckee of
zerorez joins us to share how carpet
professionally cleaned can have you and
your family enjoying a cleaner and
healthier home while escaping that
summer heat so ben
why why do you think summer is the best
time in your opinion welcome back guys
by the way oh it's good to be here well
it's summer time you know our kids are
out of school finally it's time to get
our houses cleaned up right um back to
like new condition and there's no better
way to do that than by getting your
carpets professionally cleaned freshness
right yeah bring the freshness in you
know it's we've got the heat it's it's
hot let's just get your carpets cleaned
up and looking good right and when you
you know during the summer we're trying
to escape the heat like i said you have
people coming over to your house looking
at what we're seeing on the floor right
now that would be embarrassing
it will be
so don't don't be the shame of the
neighborhood get your get your carpets
cleaned and we're going to do it in the
most like technologically advanced
process ever at zero rez we clean with
science rather than just like focus
focus stuff we're using patented
technology it leaves your carpets
cleaner than any other cleaning uh
compound out there right and the best
part is it dries soft to the touch like
it just came from the factory okay well
with that said it's time to see what the
point you said no hocus pocus but i have
to say this is also magic okay it is
magical
it is also magic so what's happening
right now so we got this hooked up to
our truck mount that's parked outside
imagine not having a 300 horsepower
vacuum
this water we call it zr water okay it's
what our patented technology is based on
it is heated up to near 230 degrees at
the truck
so we're able to clean it through the
grease the grime the dirt whatever
you've got and the best part is
even though we're cleaning and it's it's
wet it's damp to the touch it's not
soaking wet touch it
it's nearly dry see wow okay okay and
also with that you know this is really
good for allergies too because
everybody's dealing with that right now
especially seasonally yeah it's your
carpet's actually the biggest air filter
at your home or at your business so by
getting it professionally cleaned you
can get that that air filter reset so it
can go back to doing its job of
filtering out dander pollen dust you
name it it's getting trapped in your
carpets also filtering out pet hair and
grime so let's talk about what you guys
do when owners have pets at home i know
it's time so if you've got a pet at home
you're probably smelling your spots
right now
it's getting hot and so that those
smells seem to come out a little bit
more we have an arsenal of products that
can safely and effectively go after the
stain and the odor that's caused by our
our beautiful furby i know we love them
but they can sink sometimes and it's a
permanent solution right
it is so i mean we can go after and
address the smell and the odor and you
can have your home back to like new
almost okay well that sounds wonderful
and you know not to toot your horn but
you guys have rave reviews online and
also you've won best of las vegas for
the fourth year four four years in a row
okay why do you think that is you know
so if you go check this out on google
yeah and not a lot of companies will
tell you to go do that because they
might be embarrassed about the reviews
but we have over 6 000 reviews with a
4.9 star average here in las vegas and
we've gotten there because we train our
technicians every single day when they
come into the office we have a dedicated
call center that works with us locally
here in las vegas they're in our office
they're our employees so they're trained
properly to provide the best customer
experience possible there we go best
customer experience and best product
look at that look at that you guys get
your homes ready all right give zero res
a call at
702-840-3333 or just visit them online
xerorezlvegas.com and take advantage of
their special offer carpets clean for as
low as 39
per room plus receive free tile cleaning
of 100 square feet
that is great thank you guys hey thanks
rocky